we've rejected something we're we're not
okay with something and so we grab for
control that's what the ego does face
your own fear own your own crap in your
life and find the joy and the love that
you already are that got buried
underneath all these other things maybe
you even got buried at the moment you
incarnated face the fear process it
allow it that actually helps the entire
Collective to heal because we're all
connected like we're a part of one Pond
one soup and when one of us does that
and really finds the love and processes
the fear it's like a light that goes off
for everybody else in the pond and it
raises the temperature of the water for
the whole pond so we're not powerless
you know we tend to look external all
the time oh look at the political
parties look at the laws face your own
fear and know that there's nothing to
fear and that you are love and you are
joy and if you find that in your life
you will change the world you'll just uh
that vibration will affect the whole
world rather than being lost in this
idea of hopelessness that we can't
affect the world that's it's not true